time now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week almost
everyone knows someone who's been
affected by cancer and it remains the
nation's second leading cause of death
with so many of us touched by the
illness the American Society of Clinical
Oncology conducted a survey on cancer
related issues the group questioned
nearly 5000 Americans including asking
how optimistic they are about finding a
cure for the disease within the next 50
years nearly half say they're very
optimistic with a little over a quarter
somewhat hopeful joining us now from Los
Angeles to discuss this and more is CBS
News medical contribute contributor dr.
David agus good morning doc yes I am a
contributor well one topic where people
seem to to be not so optimistic was in
terms of the cost of this care in this
study and the anxiety which sort of is
surrounding it what can you tell us well
you know I think it's a true worry is
that there is financial toxicity to
cancer treatment every new cancer drug
is priced 150 thousand dollars a year
two hundred thousand dollars a year you
know really in many senses it's a
predatory practice is that the prices
show are charged what the market will
bear and so patients have to worry they
have to worry do i mortgage my house to
be able to get cancer treatment and be
with my family and so it's an issue we
as cancer doctors need to address we as
a society need to address and certainly
this survey brings that to the front
that they're worried about more than
this than about toxicities from the
treatment they're worried about the
finances yeah it's a big it's a big
concern another topic that stood at and
the study David was was people's
responses to the alternative therapies
and their perceptions of them what's
what surprised you well what shocked me
is that a study was done the Journal of
National Cancer Institute showing that
people who took alternative therapies
instead of conventional therapy had a
two and a half fold higher death rate so
clearly these are drugs that have not
been shown to work and yet there's a
perception that they work as good or
better than standard conventional
treatments
and that's a fault of weak cancer
doctors and obviously we're not
educating well enough and there's not
enough hope put in the treatments that
were given and that people are going to
alternative treatments and that to me is
scary David they were also asked about
what they hope from the government as
far as cancer care goes what were some
of their wishes well the government
should fund cancer research they should
fund cancer care and I agree with both
of those you know cancer is one of the
few bipartisan issues whether you're red
or blue you care about cancer progress
because every family in this country is
affected and so the government has been
in the lead finance or for cancer
progress and our progress really has
driven the world to improve the care of
cancer so hopefully that will continue